sometimes I I could see where corn is a
net negative for guys in an individual
level but I'm just gonna play devil's
advocate here I also think it's helped a
lot of guys stay faithful and sexless
married I was gonna say that I was gonna
say that yeah so it's so true I think
there's a place for it because imagine
you're one of these guys and your wife
without a kid or two kids whatever she's
just dealing with life and I personally
am a believer in marriage I mean we get
married soon right I believe in marriage
right I believe if that can keep you
going through that period it's better to
engage in that than to actually cheat
yeah and you're going to risk a hell of
a lot and I think corn from that point
of view is good but I think too much of
it right like anything where guys don't
want to go out and do anything because
they're so yeah they're addicted to it
it stops them being about their purpose
they've got these unrealistic views of
women and for some men especially men
that are more prone to that